ah yeah you asked for it
let's learn english with guns and roses
[Music]
so guns n roses is of course an iconic
80s band
and for today's lesson we've chosen one
of their most popular
songs sweet child of mine which is
great for learning intermediate grammar
and vocabulary
now do you want to understand your
favorite music
movies series and more well we'll help
you to do it without getting
lost without missing the jokes and
without subtitles
just like sophie who says that along
with our music lessons
she has improved her english in just two
months you can too
all you have to do is hit that subscribe
button and the bell below to not miss
any of our new lessons
now let's rock and roll with guns n
[Music]
roses
so in these first lines from the song he
says her smile reminds him
of memories from the time when he was a
child that is
his childhood now many learners
actually confuse the verb to remind with
the more common verb to remember
as you probably know if we remember
someone or something
we simply have that person or thing in
our mind think about it
or can recall it from our past for
example i remember most the names of my
classmates from college
now to remind it means to make somebody
remember something
so in the song he means that her smile
makes him remember his childhood
memories
it would be incorrect to say that her
smile remembers him
of childhood memories see these two
examples
and try to guess which verb should be
used ted this is so romantic
the spot where we first met 10 years ago
oh who's this little guy oh
um he's so cute
the spot where we first met 10 years ago
do you remember the song that was
playing that night i remember how
beautiful you looked
oh um oh he's so
cute he reminds me of my old dog tumor
oh
[Music]
by the way have you seen this suffix
before
the suffix hood is used to form nouns
that describe a collection or group
a neighborhood is a collection of
neighbors people who live next to each
other
a brotherhood is a group that is closely
connected by values or
interests for example a religious
brotherhood
[Music]
however hood can also form a noun that
describes a condition
or quality childhood is the period of
being a child
now manhood or womanhood is the opposite
when one is in the period of being a man
or woman
falsehood is the state of being untrue
in other words a lie
can you think of any other words with
this suffix
[Music]
when we refer to a color as bright that
means it is a
lighter and more intense tone
so he says that in his childhood
memories
everything was fresh as the bright blue
sky
fresh in this case is a poetic way to
say that something is full of life or
exciting
[Music]
when we say that something happens now
and then
or every now and then that means it
happens sometimes
but not frequently or regularly check
out this other example of this
expression
hey hey hey hey pregnant women can't
drink alcohol
no my doctor says it's okay to have a
supervine every now and then
really which of these do you think is
another
similar expression that natives use
trick question all of these have the
same meaning
yeah i'm just pretending to watch the
game so i don't have to help out with
stuff
and monica has no idea nope every once
in a while just yell and scream stuff at
the tv
your team winning hon oh yeah anderson
just scored again
there's no anderson
[Music]
if you're staring at someone or
something you are looking directly at
them for a long time
also it can apply that your eyes are
wide open as you look
without blinking
would you stop staring at her i wasn't
staring
i was leering
hey real quick do you want to master
native pronunciation
vocabulary and even grammar well the
most
fun way to do it is with our fluent with
friends course
and today you can try it for free with
our three-part master class
so i want to give you three reasons why
you should try out
this three-part master class the first
one is vocabulary
you will learn tons of vocabulary and
not just vocabulary that you never use
and you forget
but the vocabulary that natives really
use every single day
and we'll also show you how to never
forget it the second reason
is because of pronunciation you will
learn the way that natives really speak
not at all like how you learned in
school and the third reason
is because you will learn the cultural
context so that you will be able to
understand
and laugh along with every single joke
and in addition to all of this
if you join our full fluent with friends
course you will never be alone in your
learning
because you get to join our global
community of english learners the
fluency circle
so what are you waiting for you can try
that all for free
with our three-part master class by
clicking up here or down description
below
so axel sings that if he stares at her
for too much time
he would probably break down and cry
[Music]
when talking about people to break down
means to lose control of your emotions
and start crying
as the song reinforces it can also be
seen as a noun which is spelled
altogether
breakdown example we were under a lot of
stress and i had a breakdown
[Music]
sweet child of mine is a love song the
words sweet child
are axel rose's poetic way of referring
to his love interest
more specifically he wrote this song in
reference to aaron everly
who he even married a few years later
keep in mind that this
is not a common term of endearment
now the o apostrophe seen here is just a
reduction of the connective
of so in other words sweet child of mine
of mine is one of the ways to express a
possessive construction in english
similarly to simply saying the pronoun
my my sweet child it's commonly heard by
natives in phrases such as
a friend of mine meaning a friend that i
have
see this example you hear such stories
about new york
no it's really not that bad i mean i i
for one feel perfectly safe
[Applause]
ross ross these are friends of mine from
home liam devon
this is
oh ross
[Music]
[Applause]
is the superlative of blue meaning the
most blue
in this line axel is saying this
figuratively associating the blue from
her eyes
with the blue from the skies you should
also know that sometimes natives use
superlatives to informally emphasize an
adjective without meaning it literally
example
john told me the funniest joke at work
today in other words
john told me a very funny joke at work
today
well i actually had the weirdest
conversation with joey
he was talking about rules and right and
wrong and
i had the exact same conversation you
did what was he talking about
i don't know joey hasn't had this much
trouble getting out words since we saw
him in macbeth
ounce here means a very small amount
so axel is poetically saying that he
would suffer
when he would notice any pain in her
eyes
literally speaking an ounce is a unit of
weight equal to
approximately 28 grams by the way
when written the ounce unit is normally
abbreviated as
o z
[Music]
did you hear how axel connected the
article and to the word ounce
this is something that happens almost
100 percent of the time we see the
article and
being used since it always precedes a
word starting with a
vowel sound in this case the two words
together should sound like this
announce announce
listen to these other examples
[Music]
[Applause]
loaded like a freight train
[Music]
one more time
here he's referring to a place where he
used to hide when he was young
you probably know when referring to the
past and talking about something that is
not true
or does not happen anymore we can say
the phrase used to
example i used to go skiing a lot when i
lived in colorado
now just as we hear in the song another
way to express the same idea of used to
is by replacing it with the special verb
would
so i could also say for example i would
go skiing a lot when i lived in colorado
check out this other example i mean i
was in there just
listening to them about each other
all i kept thinking about was the 4th of
july
it's just this thing every year we would
go out on my dad's boat and watch the
fireworks
mom always hated it because the ocean
air made her hair all big
my sister jill would be throwing up over
the side
my dad would be upset because nobody was
helping and then when we did help he
would scream at us for doing it wrong
so axel says that he used to go to this
place
and pray for the thunder and the rain to
quietly pass him by
to pray is a verb referring to the
religious practice of speaking to god
or a divine entity in order to give
thanks or to ask for help
axel is saying that as a child he would
pray to god so the rain and thunder
wouldn't cause any disturbance
so more literally if something passes
you by
it happens without being noticed or
fully experienced by someone
example you shouldn't let life simply
pass you by
hey if you're enjoying this lesson with
guns and roses well
you are bound to find another lesson
with songs that you enjoy
in this playlist you can check that out
by cleaning up here or down the
description below after you finish this
lesson
[Music]
mama life
had just begun
but now i've gone it's thrown it all
away
my mom